well could the definition of what it
means to be fully vaccinated soon be
changing dr fauci creating some
confusion after previously saying
booster shots are essential and should
be standard he's now walking back that
claim saying you don't need a booster
shot to be considered fully vaccinated
but admitting that could change watch
people should not be put off by the fact
that as time goes by and we learn more
and more about the protection that we
might modify the guidelines that's what
we've been saying all along by follow
the science things change and you have
to follow the data
let's bring in dr nicole sapphire she's
a fox news medical contributor dr
sapphire it's always great to see you dr
fauci saying look don't be surprised if
the goal posts move yet again in fact we
have a couple of governors that are
saying you know the definition of fully
vaccinated is not until you get the
booster shot it seems like that's where
we're going and you wonder why public
trust is kind of lost and people are
skeptical
well trace at least dr fauci is
acknowledging that the goal post may
move because it has moved multiple times
on multiple occasions throughout the
last year and a half so at least he's
saying hey it's going to change but
here's the thing i think we need to stop
looking at in terms of fully vaccinated
and non-vaccinated as opposed to should
we be looking at into fully immune
versus non-immune so what have we been
seeing well the cdc just recently
updated their data on breakthrough cases
involving hospitalizations and deaths
for september and october and the good
news is while you are still about six
times as likely to test positive for
covet if you're unvaccinated you're
still 14 times as likely to die from
covid if you're unvaccinated compared to
those who are vaccinated so the vaccines
are still doing some work however the
gap is narrowing and that is because
multiple studies as well as just
real-time data what people are seeing
you're seeing more breakthrough cases
that's because the immunity is waning
from these vaccines the longer we get
out which is why the boosters are being
recommended but here's the question
trace what about all the people who were
fully vaccinated and then got a
breakthrough infection should that be
considered fully immune or fully
vaccinated we know the natural immunity
from that breakthrough infection likely
boosted their immunity so do they also
need to get a booster it can't be so one
size fits all here it needs to be let's
be looking at immunity and with that
involves natural immunity you know what
i get asked a lot dr sapphire is and
people say you know why is it florida
has no mass mandates no vax mandates and
they're doing really well with covet
right i mean the media won't tell you
that but they are and you have some of
these blue states that have vax mandates
and have mass mandates that are not
doing very well vermont minnesota
colorado what's going on here
well really it's more seasonal it's not
necessarily the mandate or non-mandate
what we saw in the sun belt area a few
months ago was a really hard delta wave
lots of hospitalizations lots of deaths
the northeast at that time was doing
pretty okay well times are changing the
weather's changing and it's going to
flip a little bit you're going to see a
rise in cases in the midwest and the
northeast and we're starting to see that
now cases have started to plateau and
they're at a pretty significant level
but the great news is hospitalism
hospitalizations and deaths are
continuing to decline and that is
because we have high immunity rates in
the population so people just need to
move forward knowing that listen
vaccinated unvaccinated you can get
coveted you can transmit covid so make
smart decisions so today the tsa agents
have to be vaccinated or they could be
out the tsa administrator david pakowski
says this quoting here there is a
potential if you do not have an approved
exemption and not vaccinated that you
will lose your job and we also know that
a lot of these tsa agents have you know
have asked for medical and religious
exemptions they could be put they don't
get them they can be pulled right ahead
of the travel season it could be a mess
this can be a huge mess and these
mandates make no sense if they don't
account for natural immunity yeah that's
a good that's a very good point dr
sapphire happy thanksgiving to you and
yours and and we uh very much appreciate
you coming on
absolutely i went on brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now